[Applause]
hi um it's my birthday
i'm so excited i love birthdays
and we all thought it would be a really
fun
idea if i didn't know anything that was
gonna happen
today how cool is that
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the drew barrymore show
drew's birthday edition
i'm dj d knights here to get the party
started but i'm not doing it alone it'll
bring our barrymore bash to life
she's drew's bff from nbc news today
is savannah guthrie thank you so much
d nice hello to our vffs and everybody
watching at home
this is so exciting i can't believe i'm
here but we can't
really do the drew barrymore show
without drew barrymore can we so drew
come out birthday
i love you so much it is so hard not to
hug you
the weirdest thing ever i can't it's
just but hi
we haven't seen each other in more than
a year i don't know
we were texting all day yesterday and i
was like hey we're just samantha we get
to see
each other all day but i'm so have a
seat in your own show
in your own house i just want to say in
the words of pretty woman if i forget to
tell you i had a really wonderful time
tonight you know what i think you are
going to have a wonderful time you have
no idea what's about to happen right
i don't know but my mouth fell on the
floor that denise is here
dean hi derek are you there i'm free i
am
i am oh he's spinning everything for you
the vff's by the way also have your same
birthday
february 22nd 22. we're having a little
pisces party right here
i just want to say that i am super happy
to be here
and that when we met a few years ago now
i think even before we had your kids
it was love at first sight and it still
is and what i'm finding out is that
everybody feels that way around you drew
you make everybody feel like
their instant best friend that's the
picture
that's the day we met and i have that in
a picture frame in my dressing room
right upstairs
oh i love that okay i hope you have your
party pants on and it seems that you do
and your party flower which i'm in love
with we have surprise guests
check huge giveaways and so much more
coming throughout the show
but first we are going to kick off our
celebration exactly as we should with an
intimate look
at you the one and only drew
barrymore this is your life
acting before she could even walk miss
barrymore has since appeared in almost
100 movies
tv shows and miniseries on the other
side of the camera she started her
own production company when she was just
19 years old
and has since produced over a dozen
films including
charlie's angels with a combined box
office earnings over two billion dollars
that's billion with a b but that's not
all for over a decade she's spearheaded
an entrepreneurial empire that includes
a homeline eyewear hair tools
kitchenware
and an award-winning makeup brand that's
flower beauty
she's a bright light in the dark a
breath of fresh air
an eternal optimus and one wild flower
she is drew barrymore happy birthday
drew
true this is your life and these are the
people that love you